what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the eternals covering neil
gaiman's run and the dreaming celestial
has awakened right the most powerful
celestial of all the celestials who have
ever existed in the history of marvel
comics this guy is op okay so here's the
thing the initial part of this kind of
focuses on the idea of like grabbing
eternals and kind of waking them up or
at least the ones they can anyway there
is a bit of a moment when sprite is
brought before those two deviants who
would basically try to torture and
torment icarus and ultimately killed him
and then in turn he was resurrected but
basically his fright runs away right
like sprite gets away and that's that's
kind of the end of that at that point
you end up picking up with ajak now
remember ajak is one of the more
important eternals who exist out there
the reason for this is because ajak
historically has been the speaker to the
celestials which is to say of all the
eternals who exist out there ajax the
only one that can ever really talk to
them now the question you're probably
asking yourself is why is ajak a dude
when in the movies ajax is a chick so in
reality from most of ajax history he was
a guy right that was always the case
ajak was a guy it wasn't until during
kieran gillan's run and eternals vol 5
which we covered and we kind of talked
about this that marvel changed it up the
incontinuity answer is that because
eternals have just been alive for like a
million years it's not uncommon for an
eternal to just shift things up and to
come back as a woman instead of a guy
i'm sure a lot of people out there who
are always looking for a reason to be
upset will take this as a reason to be
angry i mean it's comic books why would
you get pissed it's literally stories of
fiction
but that's kind of the way that that
kind of or at least that ajax
historically existed now the role of
ajax as the speaker to the celestials
will actually change drastically here
and it's going to be a pretty
significant moment for the character of
ajax but at the moment if you guys
recall ajax and xeros were the ones who
were used by sprite to basically tap
into the power of the dreaming celestial
by essentially creating a unimined and
then making all the eternals mortal in
the first place and so ajax being here
and communicating with zoros is one of
these things where zeros doesn't really
know exactly what's going on right xeros
is basically just a homeless guy which
is kind of weird that the leader of the
eternals would now be homeless it is
kind of a antithesis to the role that he
previously played but the important
thing here is that ajax tells zoros you
have to wake up right you're our leader
you're the greatest of us the dreaming
celestial is returning now the funny
thing about this is that neil gaiman
sort of plays it fast and loose that
unlike previous instances when you had
like druid or cersei or somebody like
that where they unwittingly performed a
unimined and then woke themselves up to
the reality of who they were that zeros
doesn't really get that and in fact
diamond kind of plays it with this idea
that like zoros sort of already knows
who he is but he's kind of shying away
from it to a degree perhaps some kind of
test or something along those lines but
it's one of these things where as soon
as ajax says like you have to come back
uh the dreaming celestial is going to be
awoken and the horde is going to come to
earth suddenly xeros is up and his eyes
light up and he was like ajax you know
he's like i'm an eternal and so it may
just be the idea of the dreaming
celestial the threat of the horde what
it represents the fact that basically it
would lead to the destruction of all
life on earth and in fact this entire
part of the galaxy itself it's enough to
just kind of jog him awake and if that
is the case it's really a testament to
the power of the horde and we'll talk
about them later on because the horde
are hugely significant right they're
really really interesting and they're
crazy powerful but at that point you
switch over to druid now remember druid
is the one who was basically the deputy
prime minister for the nation of ruseka
and now he's the one that essentially
rules it and the idea behind this is
that because there were individuals
working behind the scenes to destroy him
to cast off his rules so on and so forth
that what he does is he basically splits
them among the loyal and the disloyal
and what he does is he tells the people
who are loyal if you want to truly
demonstrate that you are a part of this
of this government of this empire if you
truly want to demonstrate that you are
loyal to me then here's a box cutter and
he's like you'll have to kill like you
have to kill one of those people who
were traders it doesn't matter who they
are but you have to kill one now one of
these guys initially goes after druid
and of course druid uses his powers to
make this guy cut his own throat and
it's one of these things where he kind
of does this as a demonstration and
saying either you can die by my hands or
you can die at the hands of my guards or
you can die by any number of ways or you
can kill those traitors one way or
another people are dying today right so
like there's no way for you to really
destroy me and the result is that the
loyal kill the disloyal right they kill
the traitors and then from that point
going on what this does is it's twisted
as it is it creates a kind of
unification even if the unification is
only out of fear when people are looking
at individuals out there who are
traitors and they haven't taken the
lives of those traitors they can still
call themselves good guys they can still
call themselves heroes but once they
cross that line once they kill them now
they're all unified in blood right every
one of them looks at the other and they
know what they did there's no way to
avoid that there's no way to look away
from it or to hide from it that's who
they are as people and that's the
reality right when it comes down to it
when people are given a choice when
they're put in a corner that they feel
like they can't get out of they will
show you who they really are and in this
instance the idea the desire to survive
is overwhelming in comparison to the
morality of taking out these traitors so
they take out the traitors because
that's who people really are right if
people come when it comes down to it if
a person has to kill you to stay alive
they will do it and so again kind of
switching over to these uh these
deviants who again have makari sort of
contained here and using him as a vector
to wake up the the dreaming celestial
they provide a little bit of history
here and one of the funny things about
this when it came to the deviants is
that the mythos behind them especially
during the roy thomas days to a degree
the dan jurgens days but with the roy
thomas days what you got here was this
kind of explanation that was pretty
straightforward really kind of building
on what kirby did but it was like the
celestial showed up on earth and they
basically called a huge portion of the
deviants to the point that they were
almost pushed to extinction because the
deviants had essentially conquered
humanity and attacked the celestials
when the celestials showed up and that
was it right no must no fuss instead
what you get is the other side of that
coin the way in which the deviants view
the celestials after all this had
happened and because they really follow
what is in effect uh largely a
theocratic society in the sense that
they believe in the celestials as gods
and so on and so forth that they had
taken this idea of them being destroyed
due to their hubris turned it on its
head and they see themselves as what is
basically an energy source that satiates
the the celestials right they see
themselves as almost kind of these
divine beings to a degree more so than
that they see the dreaming celestial as
a being that actually tried to save them
and so they really worship the dreaming
celestial more so than anything else and
we'll get a bit of an explanation about
that here in a little while but it is a
cool thing because that's how the
deviants function now from there you
actually switch over to cersei and abby
now remember cersei and abby are friends
right there is a kind of indication
there that there was a bit of romantic
history and it would make sense with
cersei i mean the way this chick is if
it walks on two legs she's probably
slept with it and so there's a whole lot
of her just kind of doing that over the
years right during that time or at least
during this segment here icarus shows up
meets with cersei and then actually
wipes the mind of abby so abby will
never remember who any of them are now
at this point it's crushing to cersei
because cersei didn't really know who
she was she had a life that she enjoyed
here she didn't know she wasn't eternal
all that kind of stuff and even after
coming to that revelation in the last
video that we talked about where she
basically realized she had powers and
that after a conversation with iron man
and their history there that she really
does seem to be an eternal she actually
shied away from it she didn't want to
have anything to do with it she's like
okay i mean maybe that's true but i like
my life here i don't want to stay here i
want to do this thing but icarus kind of
puts her in a position to where she has
to confront this now you do also have
tina and her son joey who are there and
of course that is the actual biological
son of athena which is the result of
athena basically being human and being
able to procreate where eternals
normally are incapable of doing that
with the quote unquote spell being
broken the dreaming celestial being
woken up them coming to the reality of
who they are the indication seems to be
their genetic structure goes back to
being to that of the of an eternal as
opposed to somebody just being a human
but regardless of how you slice it the
important thing is that abby's kind of
left behind now the promise that's made
here if cersei goes with icarus the
promise that's made is that abby will be
able to go back to remembering who they
were that cersei can actually give her
that but the important thing here is
that druid's aid is also needed because
there's so few eternals here that being
able to muster a force capable of at
least challenging the dreaming celestial
or bringing you know keeping him from
coming up it requires all this all the
eternals to act in unison largely
because a unimined is going to be needed
the bargain that's made between xeros
and druid is that in order for druid to
step up and to be willing to act that
the entirety of druik's nation has to
basically be left alone that it's one of
these things where i will help you but
basically my nation is wholly my own you
will never come here you will never
cause conflicts here no matter what i do
here you will never step in and the
bargain that's made is okay right like
that's it xeros goes with it and the
reason why is because xeros needs druid
more than druid needs zeros right i mean
i guess they all kind of knew each other
together but at the end of the day it's
a pretty good move made on on druid's
part right and that's kind of always
been his character manipulation
subterfuge things like that but while
all this is happening right the power of
the dreaming celestial is coalescing the
dreamy celestial is slowly beginning the
process of coming to you it's all being
observed by hank pym and janet van dyne
right two of the avengers because it's
all causing seismic activity out in san
francisco now the crazy thing about this
is that once enough energy is coalesced
and the the process is completed and
basically the dreaming celestial rises
as it stands it's colossal now initially
as it appears it's completely black now
the funny thing about this is they talk
about the dreaming celestial as being
something that's golden the whole idea
behind this though is that once you have
icarus and cersei and then these guys
who essentially show up on the scene
that they realize what's really going on
here is once the rays of the sun hit the
dreaming celestial that's when it will
turn gold right it just kind of returns
back to its normal form the idea of it
being black largely seems to be both
symbolic and literal in the sense that
it was kind of cast down into the earth
its color was changed to basically
illustrate that it was an outlier it's a
cast out celestial it's not part of the
greater celestial host and instead being
locked here seems to kind of taken its
color away of course with the sun rising
and absorbing all those energies into
itself it returns it back to its normal
color there is a bit of a fight that
breaks out between the deviants and the
eternals nothing major here right it's
not a great big huge conflict it's kind
of cool to see icarus uses the ability
to shoot energy from his eyes to
overcome these these deviants to a
degree and then some of them are turned
into like a tree right like they're
merged together into a tree and like
that's basically it just kind of locked
there kept there and just left in that
stasis but once the light hits the uh
hits the dreaming celestial and turns
them gold a couple things happen the
first is that on the blue area of the
moon the watcher who sees everything
looks away because the watcher realizes
what the threat of the rise of the
dreaming celestial truly represents the
other thing that happens is that all the
way halfway across the entirety of the
milky way galaxy where galactus is in
the process of beginning to consume an
entire world he senses the arrival of
the dreaming celestial and he gets
scared right this is one of the very few
things that scares galactus now it's
only a single page it's not overly
complex but this is enormous because
what we're talking about here are people
with just astronomical levels of power
to the layman right to the average
individual the normal human living on
earth there's no differentiation between
what the watcher can do and what
galactus can do right it's just their
power is just that high up there but
once you get up on their level and we're
looking at it from really a more even
direction there's huge differences in
what they're capable of but their power
is so extreme reality warping the
ability to create life different things
like that yet despite the power they
have the ability to manipulate and
control cosmic energies on that scale
their power is dwarfed by that of the
dreaming celestial he's just that far
beyond all these guys and depending on
what fan you talk to and i'm one of them
the power of the dreaming celestial can
rival that of eternity depending on the
situation he's just that astronomically
powerful but in the midst of this whole
thing kind of switching back to earth
with with hank pym and janet van dyne
basically contacting iron man and
telling him what's happening they arrive
on the scene now what you get here is a
bit of a skirmish between the eternals
and these avengers but it's kind of
funny because this battle is no measure
of a battle at all like quite literally
athena goes running up on iron man and
shuts the suit down like that right i
mean it's like like literally she runs
up on him and it's like done right she
shuts his suit down and then sends him
crashing into the earth and then in turn
icarus basically uses his ability to
control minds on hank pym and it's like
just stand here right now i know it's
not the most exciting thing there ever
was but it is cool to see because what
this does is it actually gives you an
idea of what the avengers are capable of
or at least what they're incapable of in
the face of the eternals the internals
were designed to be these angelic
near-god-like beings who were capable of
virtually anything so long as it falls
in the purview of being able to
manipulate cosmic energies the avengers
pale in comparison to these guys the
only person that i could see who would
really stand a chance against the
eternals as long as the fight went on
long enough would be the incredible hulk
and only because of the fact that the
hulk just keeps getting stronger as time
goes on beyond that most anybody would
lose to the eternals in an actual
physical fight now once you start
introducing like the higher levels of
thor like if you were to enter into like
the berserker state right the warriors
madness well then that totally changes
things right that starts to shift things
up but just thor walking around with his
hammer i have a hard time believing he'd
be able to successfully go toe to toe
against like 100 eternals right they
would just overpower him especially if
they went into the unimine state that
would basically end everything but as it
stands right now the the avengers are
basically just overpowered quite readily
and it's kind of a funny thing because
what you have here in the midst of all
this right while you have so you have
cersei and you got icarus talking and
you have hank pam watching it all unfold
that you actually see the dreaming
celestial stand up and that's when you
realize just how big the dreamy
celestial is this guy's half a mile tall
now here's one thing to understand when
it comes to these guys celestials do not
have a finite size the size they give us
the size that we see them in is usually
done just because of the fact that it
makes it easier to see what's actually
happening celestials can be any size
they want to be and we've seen
celestials that can be like 25 000 feet
tall that's how tall they want to be but
in reality if the celestial showed up on
earth and you saw a conversation between
the celestials and like anybody else it
wouldn't be very interesting if all you
saw was like iron man talking to a
celestial's boot because he's nowhere
near as tall as the celestial's shoe and
so that's why more often than not when
you see the celestials they're drawn to
be large enough to where it really gives
you context in terms of just how big and
imposing and powerful they are but
they're not drawn so tall that it just
comes off as weird and so during this
time because of what's going on you do
have makari who wakes up but then you
also have icarus who actually travels to
try to speak to the dreaming celestial
and then of course you have zoros and
those guys who show up and they're like
what are you doing man like ajax is the
one who talks to celestials icarus stop
being a weirdo then what you also have
is basically druid and and zuros and
then these guys who essentially form a
unimine could a unimine destroy a
celestial i don't really think so they
could destroy mostly anybody else on
earth outside of like super high level
reality warpers but the unimine is only
ever really brought together when like a
massive calamity or decision needs to be
made and this instance it is the unimine
communicating with the dreaming
celestial the crazy thing about this is
that once the unimine emerges it's
immediately shut down by the dreaming
celestial because the dreaming celestial
has no interest in talking to the human
mind now the other reason why the
unimine is formed here is because in and
of themselves if icarus were to actually
try to talk to the dreaming celestial it
would probably drive him insane and so
basically the the unimine is able to
communicate with celestials because it's
the only real way for them to handle
what a celestial saying without going
crazy in the process and so where ajax
is actually rejected by the dreaming
celestial one is taken as a personal
offense because it flies in the face of
the role that's always been his the
second thing that happens here is that
makari is awakened but the dreaming
celestial chooses to speak directly to
him initially it takes the form of
cersei because you know they've been on
again off again you know i mean over the
course of a million years he ended up
finding yourself dating the same person
a few times you know maybe they change
who knows whatever the case is that the
dreaming celestial actually tells makari
a few things the first is that the
dreaming celestial created makari that
unlike the other eternals who were
basically created by nazar the
calculator right one of the celestials
who ended up creating the eternals that
tiamu the dreaming celestial had
actually created a few beings out there
one of which was makari now we're not
really told explicitly why it is the
dreaming celestial created makari the
important thing here though is that with
the dreaming celestial awakening this
begins the process of what is
essentially the calling that this sent
out a beacon essentially to the horde
that the planet earth is ready to be
cold right ready to be destroyed all
life on it eliminated and so it'll take
quite some time for the for the cord to
get here and the dreamy celestial
something just says because the universe
is a massive place right and even at
like transluminal speed right traveling
faster than light it'll take him a while
to get here in that time i'm going to
stand and i'm going to watch right i'm
going to observe and then at a future
point in time i will judge this world
and i will decide whether or not this
world should be allowed to live or will
be destroyed that's one of the cool
things here now that's one of the more
important aspects of the dreamy
celestial because that will become very
important in terms of his character's
progression but makari will be the
speaker for the dreaming celestial on
earth now that's one of the cool things
about this right when you're a celestial
you are ancient you've been around for
billions and billions and billions of
years so for a celestial to just stand
there and observe the earth that's no
time at all right i mean that's me
saying what's up guys that's literally
it right i mean like no time passes for
this thing it's a blink of an eye in
terms of its overall existence but for
the occupants on earth they have no idea
how long this is going to go on for i
mean i guess they have until the horde
arrives so that's their window but we're
not given a time in reality there's no
real quantification that's given here he
doesn't say like i'm going to watch your
world and then i'll come to a conclusion
after a while depending on you know
things that have happened what he does
say is that in the time that he was
waking up that he was watching the world
he was looking at everything that was
happening that when he started the
process of waking up that he basically
started absorbing like radio waves and
he started absorbing television signals
and even the internet and he even read
the bible all for the purpose of trying
to understand or trying to get a better
idea of how everything exists here the
funny thing about this is that once
everybody kind of starts to wake up when
the dreamy celestial tells makari by the
way iron man's basically faking dead
over there you know they're like are you
really faking dead he's like i mean yeah
but i was just trying to see what was
going on you know trying to get a better
understanding of what's happening that
iron man's initial response is okay does
this thing really have the ability to
destroy the world and the eternals are
like oh yeah man like i mean this thing
is i mean you're talking about like the
dreaming celestial right like the
ability to destroy the world is nothing
for this guy right i mean this guy could
destroy whole galaxies if he wanted to i
mean this dude goes toe-to-toe or could
go toe-to-toe with some of the most
powerful cosmic entities some of which
you've heard of and some of which you
haven't but rest assured if this guy
wanted to destroy the world it would
take no energy for him to do it and so
the response of iron man is like well
then we have to fight it we have to find
some way to remove it and the response
of the eternals are like are you stupid
man like literally this guy could just
wipe out the whole world right i mean
like there's nothing you could do to
this guy you can't hurt it you can't
affect it nothing you do to the dreaming
celestial would even draw its its
interest in you right i mean it's no
it's like a bug crawling on you while
you're sleeping you're not gonna notice
it right it's just it's there's nothing
you can do can hurt this guy iron man i
mean i guess sure if they gather the
infinity stones right i mean yeah but
like outside of that nothing iron man
could do to could bring any harm to the
sky i mean following that you do have
this bit of a discussion where iron
man's like okay well now that you guys
are here you guys have to register right
because civil war i mean it's kind of
like iron man really dude and that's
even what the eternals say they're like
alright look man i mean we're
entertaining your presence here iron man
but understand i mean you're telling us
we have to register if you saw two
groups of children arguing over which
one of them could play in some waste
ground would you really choose sides you
know and that's one of the crazy things
about that is because the eternals just
see themselves as being so far beyond
humanity that like the the squabbles of
humans on earth over whether or not
people are registering to be superheroes
barely even concerns them well they're
like we've got much bigger things like
literally there's a half mile tall
golden statue standing here in in san
francisco and another energy source like
another enemy is gonna come here
potentially to wipe out everything in
this part of the galaxy and your concern
is whether or not we're registered to be
superheroes come on man
it's probably the most condemning
explanation of the the nonsensical
nature of superhuman registration right
i mean it's one of those crazy things
and so during this time what you
actually end up having is the deviants
who show up here right now the deviants
really are looking at this as a way to
destroy what's left of the eternals
right the blood feud never went away and
so the deviants are like we stand the
best possible chance right now if we
were ever going to destroy the eternals
right they've got four numbers they got
four to their number they got four
eternals that's all they have the other
96 are out there somewhere in the world
and they don't know that they're
eternals and if these four are destroyed
those eternals will never realize their
eternals right so if we destroy these
these four we've got six thousand of us
if we destroy these four then like it's
cool everything is copacetic and so what
you actually get here is this really
really cool bit of a challenge from
makari right this guy who can just run
super fast he says okay so here's the
deal right here's what's gonna happen he
says i'm gonna give you a shot right i'm
gonna give you three chances to hit me
if you can hit me in one of those three
shots then i will i will i will like
we'll we'll call it a day right like
i'll sacrifice to you you guys you guys
take us you know and everything's done
and over right like we're gone forever
that's the end of that but if i hit you
once all of you guys go right all of you
guys leave and so the challenge is
initially accepted by this guy crawl
right he's just kind of you know the
leader of the deviants at the moment
he's kind of like okay let's just see
what happens here right let's let's just
let's just see what goes on here and so
while that happens and makari
demonstrates his power facing off
against some of the deviants you
actually have zeros who quickly leaves
he ends up going to find uh find sprite
as he's basically trying to escape any
judgment from the eternals themselves
once he tracks him down he's basically
like you do know what's gonna happen
here right like you you took all of our
powers away you convince us that we're
human right i mean you modifying and
potentially unleashing what is basically
the dreaming celestial all this happened
because of you you have to stand for
this right and so what actually ends up
happening here is he basically breaks
the neck of sprite now sprite will
eventually be reborn as an eternal but
at the moment sprite's destroyed here
right sprite's basically dead and out of
the picture kind of the pricey pace and
so once you kind of get back to
everything that's going on you actually
have this attempt by uh by craw the
leader of the deviants to take out
makari and it doesn't work right i mean
of course because makari's so fast he
can't hit it and then he says okay fine
here's my one hit and he kneels before
him and he says chop off my head if you
can cut out like like cut off my head
right now and that'll that'll basically
end everything and so what's been going
on here kind of behind the scenes
is that with the other deviants who were
there at the beginning of all this they
were referring to makari as what was
basically called the scadroch i think
it's how you pronounce where scadrock
the whole point behind that the reason
why that name is given is because it
means he's possessed by the spirit of a
celestial and in a lot of ways that's
true he's the speaker for the the
dreaming celestial and so to attack
someone who possesses or potentially
possesses the power of a celestial or at
the very least is a speaker for a
celestial would be a massive a front
right while they don't really know
exactly what would happen the concern of
raw is that if they did do that the
dreaming celestial would destroy what's
left of them right and they don't want
to see themselves destroyed by a
celestial because there's nothing they
could do to fight against it the other
part of this though is he's like if you
really are skydrotch then we have what's
called the sky watchers doom right
basically all who love you will hate you
all who revere you will despise you all
that you care for will be destroyed only
when it ends can there be a beginning so
basically saying that like the idea of
makari being a speaker for the dreaming
celestial while he considers it an honor
the deviants consider it a curse that
everything he loves and knows will
basically be destroyed and in fact this
hits him so hard that he stands there
out in the ice for two weeks mulling the
whole thing over right just like
thinking the whole thing over trying to
figure out what what he thinks and and
how it impacts him if there's any truth
to it whether or not what he's
experiencing as being the voice of the
dreaming celestial really is an
honorable thing as he believes it is
he's more curious about it too because
this is fairly new he's never
experienced anything like this before
and so the way this ends is basically
xeros tasked icarus with going out into
the world and finding the other 96
eternals right waking up the other 90
eternals that exist out there and
basically bringing them back which of
course haman and makari end up doing
what this does is the segways directly
answer the story by charles noth which
most of you guys know because you've
heard of like the the fulcrum and all
that kind of stuff that's where all that
comes into play right that's how all
that comes into existence when the horde
actually shows up and when i'm not going
to spoil too much but a lot of really
cool things happen there kind of a fun
fact it was written about two years
after this story ended and it actually
tied into the x-men manifest destiny
storyline which was really really cool
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace